look at this guy this guy looks homeless
like one of my cousins it really goes up
the OM Brennan Sheboygan here in Indiana
on the lockdown of quarantine I'm so
bored I resorted to watching do
I got a cuter stay for ya inviting a new
girlfriend to chill at your place for
the whole entire quarantine Kenya or
sting sting the whole time nah bro just
a little dash here and one hold on
I'm gonna be locked up for months I mean
if it's a girl you are in love with yes
you know what I mean but a girl that
you're not in love with as soon as you
not dude you're gonna want to [ __ ]
kick her out
jump out of goddamn one yeah that's a
bad she better be able to cook if she's
staying out the whole time right she
would I have some supplies I teach for
serious man he's a Cubs fan you can see
that Cubs emblem he's got in the back
said eyebrows on him
we sink in his ink that's a good
question yeah would you inviting yeah
you can't invite a girl over for that
long really good chicken has you not all
your [ __ ] I wish you had AIDS load up
your bathroom eat all your [ __ ] oh yeah
oh yeah all your [ __ ] they better bring
some [ __ ] that's what I'm saying come
over supplies they bring some something
you got to watch him eat it you know you
do dude you get a ball you give her coke
sheets nothing a couple days every time
she's about to go bed to give her
another gak ur sheets and she scrubs the
whole house to be clean brainstorming
what do you want to do when you're on
math clean yeah that's true meth heads
ain't gonna get no Corona
yeah that's true yeah we didn't want to
go Bob Vila on a house when they're
[ __ ] tuned speed dude the smoke speed
and fix your cabinet speed and put a
porch on your porn
you know you got a hot tub you got a
chimney with a hot tub bringing your
apocalypse why aren't home nobody's
picking up homes people nobody
there's no no the dirtiest [ __ ]
ever get up homeless Pyrrhus nobody bro
I'm jogging the money but a homeless guy
goes yep the virus come and I'm still
homeless where's he where's he can
information about the virus oh dude the
homeless nowadays they got iPhones dude
that's true there's on Ventura there's
these two famous homeless people their
brothers two transgender brothers on
wheelchairs they live on they live on
venture with purple wigs as their plans
no no they live on they're on their
phones no they're famous
there's a there's a gas station a 76
station on the corner of Van Nuys
Boulevard and Ventura and there's a bus
stop right in front of that gas station
they've been living there for a couple
years now
now they moved over like about three or
four stores west of Van Nuys on Ventura
there's a store that is no longer in
business it's called saffron or
something and they got like a little
patio they took that [ __ ] over there
there every night to transgender rotting
homeless old dudes they got purple wigs
on and everything you know but they
don't shave they got they fought for
those rights those transgender rights
and they don't even shave that doesn't
make any sense yeah you follow those
right all right you have the wigs though
they wear the wig oh that's a minimum
they gotta have dude no I think I think
you know what if if you claim and
transgender you shave your [ __ ] face
they're homeless
come on well they put some makeup on you
fought for those rights
you got those rights but you know take
care of your face get a facial every now
and you got it - yeah I can see that the
Lord put some makeup on I'm surprised
that's not a TV show giving facials the
homeless
as people get beautifying the homeless
but used to think why are the government
why are we allowed wire homeless people
seem like they would be able to be
easily carriers of this based on like
let's stab each other just based on how
filthy they are and they're not even
picking they're not they're ignoring
them yes well how is that do we have
anybody has the disease they would get
it first it'd be the first ones to get
it yeah and to spread it and they're
just you know they're talking about
downtown's got like medieval plagues
like medieval time plagues they're
talking about going on downtown dude I
want to do a bunch of coke with and
[ __ ] attack medieval times when
they're performing dude dress up like a
rival gang I want to know where all
these [ __ ] came from the
bottoms they're like over the last June
Street here like where did they come
from
and they're all white you know what I
mean like what is going on I would like
someone to go out and interview a whole
shitload of them and get something for
me yeah where are you because nobody
lists nobody listens to him because
they're crazy no one ever wants to talk
to him that never maybe they got some
crazy stories that what if they're
telling the truth and put together these
stores will you guys come what happened
how did you end up on the streets
yeah in attempt about the culture corner
we could do it we picked up one time we
were doing the arm it was when America's
Got Talent
started it we did America's Got Talent
at loyola marymount and they said on the
way over there we're just hosting at me
and a buddy of mine for their students
and they said okay well pick up get some
judges and we said okay we picked up two
homeless guys bro named Tony and rich
from the Lincoln and Wilshire park that
parked that's right there Reid Park well
we just rolled up or like dude $40 each
if you guys just have to be cool going
stage you can you judge some people that
are performing like yeah we're good
do we roll up the curtains opens like
eleven hundred students and Tony and
rich I could judge and we go well great
bro but except for during the inner what
we hit when we had to tabulate the votes
you had to take a few minutes so Tony
was like a let me borrow that guitar
from that guy that got up there and let
me play something dude and he got up
there and literally broke
Oh riff did but he had a couple chords
dude and drop some serious [ __ ]
racial slurs
and that's when it got a little spicy
but uh-oh your is this dude yeah this
was probably 2001 okay you could do that
yeah
but the man it was crazy and Toni Dodd
and rich is still alive I see him
sometimes biking to the park sits on my
house I he don't remember me yeah what
else you got Nick we got one flaunt my
aunt
what and praise God brother thanks for
sitting in the video thank you guys you
got the girl in your place man I think
it's gonna be a long run brought a lot
of awkward breakfasts yes survival
ration that survival food you're [ __ ]
Infowars with that [ __ ] powdered
powdered scrambled eggs
hope hope you'll have lizzo as a side
view Melissa's raps are horrible if you
guys heard of rats mm-hmm I finally
listened so Megan the stallion that's
what I did four kids I think I'd be
quarantined with her you guys like our
DB oh yeah oh yeah how'd she wait for
those [ __ ] nail I don't know about
music not where I'm from she wouldn't
try yeah how even scooper but she's in
Louisiana sure yeah baby
[ __ ] it now well bro dude wiping your
ass is for the elite bro scooping your
butt is where it's at son that's where
the phrase go
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]